we've scoured the city for the hottest
new fitness disciplines these are the
workouts everyone's talking about
we've got CrossFit white I can surf set
cardio mission and boot camp it's your
body
this is fighting cardio mission focuses
on body weight exercises power abs
balance and that incorporates some yoga
moves some animal moves some traditional
basic you know knee pulls and jumping
jacks from there we move into a power so
we'll be doing burpees jump lunges
jumping from side to side we focus on
high-intensity exercise and when we do
that we help burn body fat and maximize
your muscle growth they'll learn some
new exercises that they could take with
them and perform at home and incorporate
it into their daily practice you get
much more out of it when you push
yourself and then it transfers out into
the real world
here's your cardio mission in three
minute workout so the first exercise is
a overhead squat so I'll use the towel
for this to do is you grab the towel you
roll it up you lift it above your head
and you match it just above the head
bend the elbows press up and as you
squat down you're bringing your hips
away from the mat you're reaching back
with the towel and then you exhale and
lift up next exercise is a power
exercise will do that for 45 seconds
it's called a crocodile pushup so you
get down on the floor you bring one hand
higher than the other and then you bring
the knee in to the elbow that's behind
you then you exhale and switch the next
exercise is a screwdriver on the mat lay
down bring your arms out lift your legs
up in the air and then you'll exhale and
twist the next exercise is a twisting
crane you inhale lift your arms exhale
rotate as you rotate you lift the side
that you're rotating to you lift that
knee so your lower body is always facing
straight your upper body is twisting and
your look
behind yourself so let's put it all
together for a three minute cardio
mission first exercise will be a squat
you ready one two three let's do this
inhale down exhale up bring those hips
away from the mat as you lower how you
feeling it's good it burns good you have
five four three get one more in get one
more in all right moving on
to a crocodile push up and start 45
seconds just bring the knee to the elbow
good point the knee away from the bottom
switching your head as you do your
push-ups and you're done next exercise
is a screwdriver lift the legs exhale up
twist and rotate good twist and rotate
try to keep your head open it looks yeah
come on Eric another two and one the
next exercise is a twisting crane she's
really focused for this this is all
about focus and stability inhale lift
your arms lift your leg only your upper
body twists good and slowly lower
lengthen your arms out in line with your
shoulders you have 10 more seconds
opening out through the palm the
shoulders nice foot alignment and you're
done
it was tough to balance tough gets me
yeah well that's a pretty tough all
right guys to recap 45 seconds of each
overhead squat with a towel traveling
crocodile push-ups screwdriver situps
and a twisting crane for balance now you
could repeat this circuit up to five
times for a full cardio mission
experience
alright so am I gonna see you in class I
think I have to I can't make a fool out
of myself with all this right make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any other fighting weight episodes